-Welcome, everybody.
Welcome, welcome, welcome.
Welcome to
"The Tonight Show," everyone.
You're here.
You made it.
Thank you very much
for being here, hey.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Well, guys,
I can't believe this.
Today is the iPhone's
15th birthday.
Today.
[ Cheers ]
Which means right now,
Nokia is in a bar somewhere
going, "15 years ago,
I was on top of the world."
[ Laughter ]
"You can't throw me out.
I'll throw you out."
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, I can't believe
it's been 15 years
since Apple revolutionized
the way we raise our kids.
[ Laughter ]
"Just -- Just take that."
Yeah, that's right.
The iPhone is so popular,
it single-handedly turned Apple
and rice
into a trillion-dollar industry.
[ Laughter ]
Speaking of Apple,
the FCC has asked Apple
and Google to remove TikTok
from their app stores
over national-security concerns.
[ Audience "Oohs" ]
Then Apple and Google
saw how much money
they were making off TikTok
and told the FCC
to go FCC themselves.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Yeah, they claim China
has been stealing
sensitive user data
through the app.
Apparently, they got suspicious
when Chinese engineers
started slapping each other
with tortillas.
[ Laughter ]
Pwff!
Yeah, the FCC was like,
"The risk is too great.
Putin might learn
how we make pasta in a mug."
[ Laughter ]
Meanwhile, they heard that they
can be removed from the app,
TikTok was like --
-♪ Oh, no ♪
♪ Oh, no ♪
[ Laughter ]
♪ Oh, no, no, no, no, no ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-People are still talking about
yesterday's bombshell hearing
about former President Trump.
We heard that, at one time,
Trump got so angry
that he threw his plate
at the wall
and that he got ketchup
all over the place.
And apparently,
it's inspired a new product.
Watch this.
-Say goodbye to messy cleanups
and hello to
the Trump Magic Eraser.
The best way
to clean food off your walls,
like a steak with ketchup.
[ Crashing ]
Or spaghetti with ketchup.
Even chili cheese dogs
with ketchup.
[ Splats ]
The Trump Magic Eraser
wipes it all away.
And best of all,
when you're done,
you can flush it down the toilet
like a classified document.
-Bye-bye.
-The Trump Magic Eraser.
A-a-a-and he's getting sued
by Mr. Clean.
-I just thought
that was interesting.
That's an interesting
commercial.
[ Applause ]
Well, guys,
it's been a tough couple of days
for the Giuliani family.
First, Rudy Giuliani -- I don't
know if you heard this --
he claimed that he was assaulted
at a grocery store.
But security footage
showed that it was
more of a pat on his back.
[ Laughter ]
And then, last night,
Rudy's son, Andrew Giuliani,
lost the Republican primary
for New York governor.
Yeah. His biggest weakness?
Name recognition.
[ Laughter ]
It was a tough night for Andrew.
He gave his dad a big hug,
and then Rudy accused him
of assault.
[ Laughter ]
Did you guys see this?
I read that Nissan
is recalling more than 300,000
Pathfinders
over risk of the hoods flying
open while people are driving.
[ Laughter ]
Turns out Nissan was using
the term Pathfinder ironically.
[ Laughter ]
Speaking of cars,
due to high gas prices,
fewer Americans are going
on summer road trips.
But just 'cause
you're staying at home
doesn't mean you can't feel
like you're on a road trip.
So I thought I'd share
some of my
home road-trip tips right here.
First, every half-hour,
randomly point somewhere
in the room and say, "Cow."
[ Laughter ]
Next, use your own bathroom
but flush with your foot.
[ Laughter ]
And, finally, have your kid
sit on the couch
and threaten to turn
this whole house around.
"We're going --
We're taking --
I'm gonna take
the whole house back."
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's just like the real thing.
Hey, guys, listen to this.
Whole Foods said that,
as the pandemic eases,
they're focused
on holding down prices
for their customers.
It's true. Take a look at this
commercial they just released.
-We here at Whole Foods
are committed to our customers
and will continue selling our
products at reasonable prices,
like a bunch of bananas
for just $14.99.
[ Laughter ]
Apples for just $9.99 a pound.
That's cheaper
than a gallon of gas.
And this ripe avocado that costs
just 3 easy payments of $99.99,
a $200 down payment,
a security deposit,
and your firstborn child,
plus shipping and handling.
Whole Foods --
Stay in your lane, Erewhon!
-Oh, interesting, wow.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
Well, some TV news.
NBC is coming out with
an eight-part series
on dinosaurs,
called "Surviving Earth."
Spoiler alert -- they don't.
[ Laughter ]
Hey, I heard that the Academy of
Motion Picture Arts and Sciences
just invited
397 new members to join.
Yeah, it's pretty exciting.
One of the new members said...
-[ Gibberish ]
-While the other 396
were like...
[ Gibberish ]
-Pbht!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Unbelievable.
Well --
Well, this is fun.
I saw that "Back to the Future:
The Musical"
is set to debut on Broadway
in 2023, yeah.
That's pretty big news,
and if you're wondering
what it'd be like, we got our
hands on a sneak preview.
Take a look.
♪♪
-♪ Doc ♪
♪ You're my only hope ♪
♪♪
-♪ This is it ♪
♪ This is the answer ♪
♪ It says here ♪
♪ A bolt of lightning is gonna
strike the clock tower ♪
♪ Precisely at 10:04 p.m.
next Saturday night ♪
♪ Hm-hm, ha ha ♪
♪ Ha ha, hm-hm hm-hm ♪
♪ Next Saturday night ♪
♪ We're sending you
back to the future ♪
-Whoa!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Bravo!
[ Applause continues ]
And, finally,
Air New Zealand has announced
that they are adding the world's
first lie-flat pods
to economy class.
Here they are.
This is real.
[ Audience "Oohs" ]
Now the guy who hogs the armrest
will be spooning you.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Wow.